- I hate Thai food.
- I love Thai food.
(upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] This looks
like an egg sandwich.
- It's like a little taco.
- It tastes exactly like a fortune cookie.
- Ooh it's got a ooh.
Ooh it's got a ooh.
It's like got a tangy orange flavor.
- Is it coconut?
Is it colored coconut?
- No it's mine.
- I'm not a big fortune cookie fan.
I know that's ironic, but I'm not.
- [Voiceover] What is happening?
- [Voiceover] What's going on here?
- I think we're gonna eat unicorn hair.
- Ooh.
- Interactive desserts.
- Thai people are all about the tacos.
- I think I just poked one up my nose.
I'm really sorry.
- [Both] Cheers.
- I love this.
- This is fun.
- It melts in your mouth the
same way cotton candy does.
- I feel like Rumpelstiltskin.
Like, turn it to gold.
No?
(both giggling)
- [Voiceover] This is (beeping) phallic.
- What is Durian?
- That's the thing that smells really bad.
- You're not advertising this well.
- Whoa no!
- It smells like mango puss throw up.
- Oh it tastes great.
- It's like a gummy
bear that's turned evil.
- Okay it does taste
better than it smells.
- It's like a very tame
version of the smell.
- Is it a pancake?
(gibberish noise)
- I love Taro Boba.
- It smells like a doughnut.
- Oh dear.
- It is so good.
(groaning)
- Well okay.
- Is that corn?
- This thing may as well tell it's parents
it's dropping out of high school.
Cause it is disappointing me.
- It's like an Almond
Joy without the chocolate
or the nut and with purple.
- [Voiceover] Looks like salted poop.
- Look at these little turds.
- Oh that's hard.
- Its a seed.
There's a seed.
- Wait, what is going on?
Is it spicy?
Is it sweet?
- Ugh ugh.
- Oh but now I'm kinda into it, okay.
- It's salty at first.
And then sweet.
And then spicy.
- Dessert is supposed to
be a treat after dinner.
This is like a (beeping) you after dinner.
- It took me for a joy ride.
It said, "Get in, shut
up, because I'm driving".
- [Voiceover] This looks
like lunch, not dessert.
- You have to work for
your dessert in Thailand.
- What is in there?
- It is a baby alien.
I knew it.
- Oh there is banana in here.
- This is a mushed up
banana inside of rice.
(growling)
- Oh my god!
- Mmm, it's not bad.
- I like that.
- It's like rice pudding,
except a gummy bar.
- Whenever you have anything
that looks like a taco
or a burrito, you're killing it Thailand.
- Not the biggest fan of the spices.
- I am really wowed.
- Two thumbs up.
- Nothing like Thailand.
- So good.
- Talking 'bout Thailand.
So good so good so good, yeah.
- Are you supposed to eat this part?
- You might of just killed us!
We're probably not supposed to eat these.